so you're currently shooting season 2 of
13 reasons why was that going what can
you tell us about it so far I can tell
you that we're deep in the thick of it
getting around on a plane after this to
go back and do more tomorrow and you
know it's much any episodes of you shot
so far we got a few in the bag we're not
not not really halfway through but we're
getting there getting there I'm excited
that I get to feedback and work with the
people that I love because I love
everyone on this show but it's also I
think really exciting that we get to
continue the conversation that we
started in the season one so I'm excited
this show is incredible in that it
really has sparked so much conversation
about so many issues how has the show
taken that conversation onboard and
integrated it into season two or has it
whoa I mean that's a really good
question I'm not sure how I can answer
that without giving away too much about
season two all I can say is that I feel
like I feel yeah I feel like we continue
the discussion from season one but I
yeah I don't I don't think I can say
much more than without without spoiling
anything so we have to wait I think that
every single word from everyone across
the world has been heard by everyone
involved at the show whether that will
have an impact or change the
storytelling that needs to be done in
season two I don't think so
I think they're gonna again just tell
the story that we feel needs to be told
and how we want to tell it and and try
to do the best job that we can like last
year I think the response to the show
was definitely it was it was
overwhelming and I think anyone really
expected it to be received the way it
was but you know I'm very proud of the
show and I'm really really thankful that
I've been able to be a part of to be a
part of it
[Music]